[Music]
after 30 years
mcdonald's is leaving russia damn and
they're smiling all of their restaurants
because of the because of the war
because the war yeah that makes sense
are they selling it are they selling it
including the branding are they only
selling they're not selling it with the
branding they're basically just selling
the restaurants to someone else yeah to
whoever is now it's gonna be crackdonald
[Laughter]
who buys those spaces and i'm wondering
if they like just keep all because you
know how like some some spaces move into
other restaurants and they don't change
it yeah you're talking about i know
you're talking about noodle world moving
into bob's big boys
and they just kept the big boy there
because like you would see like old
school signs like the winchell's [ __ ]
triangle sign but they change it or taco
bells taco bells are so iconic when they
change that you're just like or that's
still a taco bell or any place that's a
wiener schnitzel it's like a [ __ ] hut
yeah
yeah just like you ain't no dinner
that's what happened all the pizza huts
remember they all used to look like huts
like they were in the logo yeah oh yeah
yeah with the red hut yeah same with
shakies in russia right a lot of the
businesses are state run but they're
owned by oligarchs so what is this what
will be the oligarch version of
mcdonald's
right and like are they gonna be the
comrades
i don't know i don't know anything about
russian like
politics or like who the big players in
russia i just know that there's a lot of
oil there so they have a lot of natural
gas yeah they're billionaires but it's a
oligarchy yeah yeah right so mcdonald's
doesn't they don't even own every
mcdonald's there like they only own like
a they want like a obviously like a high
amount but they're they're pulling out
is this a is this a political move yeah
because they said they just can't um
support the humanitarian crisis that's
happening and it's reputationally too
expensive it also sounds like a [ __ ]
headache to just figure out logistics in
a country where you're [ __ ] dumb like
you're where your currency is like
crashed
oh yeah like why bother have the
headache and then have all these other
people being like we support russia just
[ __ ] yeah people's is actually like
the top performing currency right now
it's not better than luna what happened
because it like took a dump like when
the war cracked out right but yeah right
now i think it's the top performing
currency i heard though so they luna and
then they recovered yeah yeah maybe
people bought the gif
sanctions aren't working man what the
[ __ ] the cool thing is that even though
they're leaving they are trying to
implement into place some kind of uh
switch-off where people won't lose their
jobs they're like yeah they're like
they're trying to find a seller who can
take it
when they transition to make comrades
dude their uniforms are all sick it's
all [ __ ] red and yellow
can you sovietize me please
just smaller
[Laughter]
you don't get a choice of there's no
like soda found it's just soda like
there's just it's just water
there's just state-owned soda vodka or
diet
so we're seeing it from the restaurant
side right like but there's like a whole
supply chain inside of there that
mcdonald's is operating yeah their own
logistics their own logistics and
everything are they pulling out of that
as well probably yeah i'd imagine yeah
because like a trucking company there's
like freezer storage right right holy
[ __ ] i wonder what their menu is over
there because they have like regional
like specific yeah mcdonald's items in
every country right i wonder what's
going on burgers
this guy is our resident russian expert
he knows everything about watching what
is it not chef's table one of those like
food food netflix shows and they're
showing all these delicacies and then
one of them was they're like there's
this russian chef he's like he's like in
the stables petting these moose
he's like i love my moose or whatever
and then the next time the next edit was
a plate full of like
[ __ ] just tongues laying there
i was like oh [ __ ] with the head or just
just tongues just [ __ ] tons of
tastebuds
oh dude it actually says that in the
russian mcdonald's they have chicken
wings shrimps uh the breakfast menu has
cheesecake rolls oatmeal
and something called blini
that's normal [ __ ]
they don't got sturgeon and [ __ ]
where's the moose tongue dude why was i
thinking moose knuckle
that's all american brother
have you guys tried like the different
items at four in mcdonald's yeah oh dude
yeah the malaysian mcdonald's has the
best spicy chicken nuggets really
uh pork burgers in thailand oh this was
ages ago i don't know if they still have
it now does hawaii still have a little
pineapple in the big mac or in the you
know they put pineapple slices in the
burger last time i went i didn't see
that you can get like a side of rice too
you got like ube pies
yeah breakfast they're like
hawaiian breakfast yeah
spam and the portuguese sausages oh
they're prestige
in japan they have uh koroke burgers so
it's just all carb so it's like you know
the koroke it's like that deep fried
potato yeah oh and then they put that on
sandwich carb carb carb it's basically a
potato sandwich yeah i have like a
chicken sandwich for breakfast or like a
little bit of wasabi in it
yeah so the russian menu has uh like
shrimp roll mick combo it's like a fried
chicken i think
yeah fish rolls france has a good uh
mccafe and pastries oh yeah yeah
it's pretty good there they have actual
like good coffee and stuff and when we
went there they took bitcoin
really yeah they took bitcoin on the on
the [ __ ] uh machines it was crazy huh
pretty ahead of their time there yeah
because back then dude bitcoin was like
a thousand bucks a coin so
yeah have you guys ever done any bitcoin
transactions like at a store like out of
cash i'm about to i'm gonna go to el
salvador in a few weeks oh [ __ ] and
everything like every most of the stores
have like bitcoin oh wow except you send
it to the
i think it's like they address chivas
wallet or something
that's like what they use to like get
your bitcoin that's insane so i'm
curious to see like logistically can you
make a video of it i want to see what
the whole process looks like i don't
know if i want to spend my bitcoin
because it's like in the dumps right now
look at this look at this mini doesn't
it look aggressive slightly
it's like why are you yelling at me it's
an old one but like it's got that feel
huh it's got the soviet feel yeah
it feels oppressive
i'll kill you
[Laughter]
straight to jail
was that proved by putin yes
encouraged by i wonder what putin likes
to eat i wonder what food store i don't
know what putin's favorite like fast
food place leaving he's like no
that gives him that that makes him stop
the war he's like [ __ ] it yo it's like
fine you broke me
i have a friend um him and his brother
ate dinner with putin by accident
what do you mean
they have a
they have a conglomerate group in
vietnam
and um one of their investors is a
oligarch slash
like top-ranking military official in
russia of course and because you know
rich people all over the world got their
hands all over the world right so he
invited him to st petersburg they went
out there
and um you know these guys are like
american
born vietnamese dudes that are in
vietnam and the russians didn't know
they were americans they just go we love
vietnamese you know we've been friends
for a long time whatever whatever
and then so um
yeah they they went downstairs to eat
but i guess like saying petersburg has a
lot of billionaires and [ __ ] their
hamburgers were like a hundred bucks and
even though these guys are rich they're
still american vietnamese dudes that
will not pay a hundred dollars for a
hamburger right so they went across the
street got a six bag of beer and then
their investors dude come there for
their dinner yeah they're a beer they
had a six pack of beer drink for dinner
thank you but how are your question of
them
they're uh uh the guy shows up and then
he's like oh
did you guys have dinner yet and they're
like oh no we you know we're just
chilling with these beers and then he's
like well you should have dinner with us
uh but you know dress appropriately and
then he's like okay so then they get
into their like business clothes and
stuff
and then they get you know they drip
they get driven out they go to this
place
they go up
it's like this elevator that's private
there's this table laid out and he goes
there's already food laid out everyone
sits down and then there's like people
in like military outfits
and then this guy rolls in
and they're like oh crap that's putin
what the [ __ ] right
and then like so they're just nudging
each other like that's poo putin that's
food that's food they just don't speak
english all right speak vietnamese and
then you're like speaking vietnamese the
whole time he's like i can hear you guys
over there
i can hear the americans
they're just speaking vietnamese the
whole time because they thought they
were vietnamese nationals yeah that's
scary
and then he's like damn what the heck
and then after that i guess like
yeah they wanted to take pictures but
they they're too scared no [ __ ] that
no you gotta do one of those far away
like selfie ones yeah is that worse if
you get caught though or just worse to
ask oh yeah that's true talk to remember
when that story about how uh like i
don't know it's true but putin like
asked to see like a nfl championship
ring from some guy
oh he just took it right she walked away
with it
i forgot what i forgot who it was but i
did hear that story he's like oh this is
cool
what do you say after that right how he
just like put it on he's like oh like he
said can i see that and then he put on
and then he just walked away what did
they do the guy was like wait and then
putin's guard was like
yeah he's like say goodbye that's it he
just stole his [ __ ]
do you see all those photos of mma
fighters taking pictures with putin or
like mcgregor would be like this and
then the guard would be like no and he
goes yeah yeah yeah habib could put his
arm around him
[Laughter]
come on this guy's gonna stop the war
[Laughter]
in russia putin is like he's portrayed
as this servant of the government he
only makes a hundred thousand dollars
lives in us in like a little apartment
in the city kind of thing but now people
are starting to find it like it's true
like one of his yachts were seized his
yacht costs almost a billion dollars
what wow
multiple yachts multiple yachts how big
is it it's like a small cruise line yeah
into something that's exactly what my
buddy told me is that um the same one
that went to go eat with putin by
accident he said that that forbes list
is utter [ __ ] completely incorrect
because all these guys know who the rich
people are and they will never put
dictators
and you know right dark matter you're
not going to make a people political war
over it no but he goes yeah those guys
on the whole like the like the un family
uh i mean the kim family like kim
jong-un all them like right that family
alone owns north korea
if you think about it right so all their
factories everything that's
theirs so that calculates into the
ultimate like worth right yeah so then
if you think about putin and it's like
russia but technically he is russia
so he owns a lot of that [ __ ] you think
kim jong bought aboard ape
i wouldn't be surprised because i heard
that they have a lot of bitcoin
actually north korea
north korea is one of the the centers of
all of the bitcoin and crypto hacking in
the world oh hacking they jack bitcoin
so there's this there's this popular
game called axi infinity oh yeah one of
the biggest blockchain games of of the
time right and they have this token
called ronin right that's the ronin
network is where all their transactions
happen
so i remember i was at nft la a couple
months ago and up comes the ceo of of
actually to talk about his thing and you
can see that this guy is clearly like
he's disturbed
and so as he was coming on the host is
like hey i know you're in a hard moment
let's just ask you a couple of questions
at that point in time axi infinity was
hacked and the ronin network i think
there's billions of dollars that are
siphoned off from it and nobody know who
did it and so they finally found out a
couple a couple weeks ago that's the
north koreans oh they have this group of
hackers i forget the name of it but
pretty much any of the largest crypto
hacks are happening are all done by the
north koreans it's crazy i think the
hacking group is called anonymous sayo
you